a is free good Act does not wash out the
bad nor a bad to good
B is for but now I'm the rightful king
by every law of Westeros c is for family
and take this city
D is for do your knucklebones bring you
luck
e is for every man on storms end wanted
to kiss you that night I was relieved
they did not G is for do you do H is for
our truths cut both ways
of us I is for I've said the words down
here J is for Joffrey Renly Robb Stark
they're all thieves they'll bend the
knee or I'll destroy them k is for kneel
before me lay you sword at my feet
pledge me your service and you'll rise
again as John Stark Lord of Winterfell
L is for that no man claim ignorance as
an excuse M is from that's Raider you've
been called the king-beyond-the-wall
Westeros only has one king M is for
never liked cats so fine oh it's for
well you could see if this tormund fell
is more willing to compromise than mance
so was I assume the Brothers of the
Nights Watch would rather see the
wildlings dead
P is for refugee Dustin Davos how much
mercy I show the lawbreakers Q is for
are easy Robert told me to hold storms
and so I held it then he told me was
giving it to Renly so I gave it up
insult oh no I gave it up yes inspector
too much kindness people won't fail you
if they don't feel you they don't follow
you
t eSport the Iron Throne is mine by
right all those that deny that are my
foes U is free unless I triumph I never
asked for this normal than I asked to be
king V is from very well W is for what
is the life of one bastard boy against a
kingdom X is 4 y is strictly with a
princess Shireen of house Baratheon then
you are my daughter
[Music]
z is for why you don't have strength I
will kill you I'm not so easily killed
men have been trying for years